most people that i know like to leverage
debt in their favor facts because it's
like i mean credit is pretty much just
your history of borrowing money so at
the end of the day the bigger [ __ ] you
want to buy is the bigger record of [ __ ]
you have to have on your record of
actually borrowing and paying it back
even if you can even if you got the
money all right i'm still like i can go
buy a macbook right now i just bought a
brand new desktop computer but i just uh
financed it just because just so i could
just come on my account and just add to
my credit score to show like i'm still
paying or something in a positive way so
i mean it's just so many like life hacks
when they come to like finances and
financial literacy i think it's out
there just to research it though yeah i
watched so many youtube videos because
like you know uh especially with the
credit thing like i always i started
telling a lot of people close to me like
yo if you can afford
to just
use your credit card for everything but
you have to pay it off to zero every
month or you're gonna get you know
credit card
interest rates are interest rates
they're horrible so i'm gonna give you
another hack though so if say if you got
too much money on a credit card let's
you know they give you like 12 or 16
months free
you can do a balance transfer to a brand
new credit card and transfer your whole
balance and get a whole another 16
months on a new credit card with that
same balance without the interest rate
without the interest rate wow
so that's what most people really be
doing like they'll open up a credit card
with union bank
run up like 10 15 000
until the year hit up and at the end of
the year if they're not ready to pay
that off all they're doing is just
switching that balance transfer over to
another bank yeah and they giving you
another 16 months to be like oh i just
use my credit card for everything and
then i just pay it down to like two
dollars every month no in fact that's
what i do as well because i don't even i
don't even want to go through because
then if you use your credit card and
some some some [ __ ] happens or
it's it's you're totally not liable for
it you know like it's
if you use your debit card all the time
let's say you swipe it at the gas
station and someone [ __ ] takes your
[ __ ]
that's your actual money that's missing
that's your money that's gone and then
now you gotta wait for the bank to get
their [ __ ] together if that happens with
your credit card you're like oh well
[ __ ] it i've cancelled my card you guys
will figure that [ __ ] out right it's not
coming out of my house
wait my money yeah but that's a great
way to like just build your credit right
it's just
yeah credit is
a like not a lot of like like there's a
lot of misconceptions about how people
get credit
people like man i gotta have my phone
for
six years bro i'm like that [ __ ] don't
matter i said do not matter bro it only
matters if you don't pay it car notes
leases
house notes real [ __ ] you gotta find
credit cards everyone should get a
credit card and then another thing you
can do is
you can add like if you have kids you
can add your children
as an authorized user on your credit
card right to start building their
clients my mom got me right yeah my mom
taught me all this [ __ ] so it was like
definitely early on she was on my ass
about credit card utilization all that
type of stuff